there are myths of creativity and these
myths are usually propagated by people
that have romantic notions about heroes
romantic notions about Eureka moments
and these myths of creativity keep
people from collaborating and it causes
them to be a lone wolf and the research
says it causes them to fail so let me
talk a little bit about those myths of
creativity in the world of sales and
marketing I battle against three myths
myth number one the lone inventor this
is very dangerous because there is no
such thing as a lone inventor as a
matter of fact there's a lot of
historical research that has debunked
Einstein specifically in terms of
inventions Henry Ford not a lone
inventor a classic example Thomas Edison
in the invention community Thomas Edison
is a brand it stands for fourteen people
yes there was a figurehead named Thomas
Edison his name is on 10,000 patents he
did not invent a single thing he
marshaled people together and knew how
to spot innovations and put people
together like a creative soup if you
will here's a classic example Steve Jobs
you know you ask the average person say
a millennial who uses a lot of Apple
technology who's one of the greatest
inventors of our time they'll say Steve
Jobs Steve Jobs once said I never
created anything all I did was notice
patterns and put people together to
finish projects so think about it if he
doesn't have Wozniak there is no
original Apple right if he doesn't have
I've there is no iPod if he doesn't have
Tony Fadell there is no iPhone and the
list goes on and on got a good friend of
mine David Burke as he wrote a really
wonderful book of about the myths of
genius and he was telling me that it's a
romantic notion and I remember when I
first read this research years ago no
lone inventor it did kind of hurt my
feelings
I'm a musician in my past I thought I
wrote a lot of songs but according to
the research I didn't never wrote a song
I always collaborated with somebody the
song that actually made it to the
made it on the radio had 15 to 50 hands
on it when I talked to David I said when
I read your research kind of hurt my
feelings he goes it's a romantic notion
because we want to be heroes we want to
be as empowered as ein Rand we want to
think that we are the fountainhead so
this is how we tell the story but until
you believe that genius is a team sport
you will never give up control and this
is the problem for a lot of people in
sales they don't want to cede any level
of control over their process to
somebody outside of sales world because
they don't value those voices enough but
the research is clear on this Miller
Heiman Institute researched the
difference between good and great they
call it world class organizations they
win they sell twenty percent more than
their nearest competitor the only thing
they have in common is they've broken
this myth and they understand that every
deal is about rapid problem solving and
no one person can solve the problem on
their own quickly the other two myths of
creativity that must be dispelled is the
Eureka moment there is no such thing as
a big idea that changes the world I know
this is another one of those hurtful but
very true based on empirical research
points there are little ideas that
combine with other little ideas that
improve themselves into game-changing
ideas and I've experienced this
personally about who I consider one of
the authorities on creativity am IDI
Catmull president of Pixar I remember
standing backstage a few years ago just
gushing to him about John Lasseter I'm
like John Lasseter his VP of creative
I'm like he's the bomb this is the guy
who wrote wall-e the commercial this is
the guy that wrote the script for Toy
Story you know telling the story from
the toys point of view and I remember a
cat will looked at me cut me off and not
to dismiss Lasseter he said Toy Story
was a problematic idea from the start
make an entire full-length feature film
inside a computer do you understand how
hard that is from a rendering time
standpoint make the characters as human
as human they didn't even have facial
controller technology at the time for
this and tell the story from the toys
point of view when we've never
historically had a toy have any
narrative for us to draw
on cat will explain that nine months in
there shut the film down after a meeting
with Disney they called it Black Friday
and think cat will said something to me
that shattered the myth of the Eureka
moment cat will said Toy Story the movie
you saw was a thousand problem solved
and it was like it was like a bolt of
lightning I was like I get it when you
do a million dollar deal in an ad agency
it's not a big idea it's a hundred
problem solved 80 of them are inside
your agency as you move through every
level of that sale you get obstacles in
front of you and what this means is that
if we no longer depend on the big idea
to fall out of the sky and change the
world we meet more we think more we
research more we settle with small
pieces of progress that add up to
momentum finally the third myth of
genius or creativity that must be
shattered if you want to be more
collaborative is the myth of the expert
now I believe in involving people in a
deal storm who we think are experts on
the problem space but if you notice I
don't want experts on the solution space
because most of the great solutions to
vexing problems come from the edges of a
domain you know people that don't know
what they don't know so they're not
limited by these false constraints that
hold people back that are in the middle
of this subject so the way I like to
think about it is if you could talk to a
fish if you could if the fish could
respond if it could and you walked up to
a fish in a fishbowl and you asked the
fish how's the water the fish would look
at you puzzled and ask you what's water
and that's the problem with experts
people that are so steeped in a domain
they don't have the expansive
perspective that allows them to
recognize patterns and convergence
because every invention every solution
is really about pattern or convergence
recognition and so it's really important
for us to follow the following mantra in
collaboration ideas can come from
anywhere as a matter of fact in deal
storming that is one of my four key
ground rules it's just as important as
stay on agenda and don't distract the
person next to you because the problem
with the myth of expert
is it leads to not invented here
dismissal of good ideas so when you're
in a deal store meeting and someone
who's on the edge of the domain I'll
just give you an example someone out of
finance that generally handle something
as mundane as revenue recognition they
come to one of your meetings because you
have a problem related to how you
recognize the revenue of this deal or
whatever and you're in the middle of
this conversation about packaging and
they come up with a really novel way to
think about how it's built
you might look at that person and say
you don't know anything about billing
sales you're just a revenue recognition
analyst we know billing and sales you're
about to shut him down for the rest of
the meeting and what you don't
understand is that he may have an
educational background he may have had
previous jobs he may have a significant
other that is steeped in the billing
expertise and he's drawing upon all that
the minute you tell someone only experts
can weigh in with ideas everyone who's
not an expert stops contributing and in
my experience it breaks down
collaboration